Pete Budaj is keeping busy after his
Democratic presidential run the former
mayor of South B Indiana was spotted
just yesterday in the lobby of a hotel
where Senator kamla Harris is preparing
for her vice presidential debate
tomorrow he is reportedly playing vice
president Mike Pence in those
preparations reportedly Budaj is also on
Joe Biden's transition Advisory Board
and he's been working at the University
of Notre Dame top of all that during his
downtime he's written a new book it's
called Trust America's best chance and
mayor Budaj joins us now uh mayor good
morning to you you're in Salt Lake City
now you're from Southbend are you there
for the skiing or something
else so uh can't speak to anything going
on behind the scenes with the campaign
but uh of course Salt Lake City tomorrow
will be a venue for a very important
conversation and I'm looking forward for
the opportunity for Senator Harris to
speak directly to the American people
about why we need Joe Biden as our next
president well you're a skilled debater
yourself so I'm curious what you think
the the strengths of Vice President
Pence are as a debater and how uh
Senator Harris is preparing to meet
those
straints well the truth is he's a very
effective debater I've seen him uh
debating for governor uh and uh uh
debating for vice president as well he
has an ability to deliver lines with a
high degree of confidence whether
they're true or not but of course saying
something with a straight face doesn't
make it true and what's going to be
really important I think is for
Americans to really see the difference
between uh a message from an
Administration that doesn't seem to want
to face reality uh and uh the the Biden
Harris campaign represented by Senator
Harris talking about what it'll actually
take to confront this pandemic that's
now killed more than 200,000 Americans
and that the White House still seems to
be in denial about even with the
president getting sick if the vice
president wanders from the truth as you
say how will Senator Harris respond well
you know it should be the job of the
moderator and so I'm hoping that uh
we'll be able to rely on that uh
factchecking so that uh she can focus on
getting out uh the message about how
this country is going to move forward
what it's going to take to uh as the
vice president likes to say restore the
soul of the nation and what that better
Vision looks like one of the issues that
did come up in the presidential debate
from a couple weeks ago was whether Joe
Biden wants to expand the Supreme court
and he he didn't answer the question but
you're an interesting person on this
subject because you have supported a
plan to add justices So it's 15 uh it's
not Court packing it's a little bit more
complicated than that uh but given your
support for expanding the court and
given that it was an issue in the last
debate I'm curious could we see an
answer tomorrow night to that
question well I think what we're going
to see tomorrow night is a conversation
about what's at stake right now we we've
got uh less than 30 days till the
election and and a matter of weeks
before the court May entertain a case
that could decide whether pre-existing
uh care cover it pre-existing condition
coverage is taken away from millions of
Americans as Republicans try to
overthrow the Affordable Care Act in its
entirety I think those really urgent
questions are going to command the most
attention because this is a nomination a
re live nomination not a theoretical
exercise uh that could be coming before
the senate in a matter of days it's so
interesting that your book is coming out
at this time what's the name of it again
[Laughter]
so the book is called trust am chance
right I it's only more timely by the day
I know I see it behind you that was that
was an attempted humor but it's so
interesting that I've gotten calls from
both Democrats and Republicans Pete who
asked this question when it first when
he when the president first became ill
do you really think that he's ill I was
shocked that so many people from both
parties were asking that question what
does that say about trust you write in
your book Society work works best when
people trust so what happens when people
can't trust
yeah well it shows you the point that
we've come to I mean consider the
position of uh this uh physician the
doctor to the president he represents
three of the institutions that are
supposed to be the most trusted in the
world he works for the White House he's
an officer in the military and he's a
doctor we should be able to trust people
connected to those institutions
implicitly but today we can't and that
is an incredibly dangerous thing with
Americans unsure about something as
fundamental as the physical condition of
the president of the United States but
it's not just about his health our own
health depends on trust you know right
now researchers are racing against the
clock to develop a vaccine and yet
there's polling indicating as many as
half of Americans would hesitate to get
one uh getting that life-saving vaccine
prevents individuals from getting sick
it also prevents individuals from
spreading the disease just one example
of how a concept that sounds very
theoretical like social trust that's a
life and death issue yeah you you say
the highest compliment you can pay a
friend is I trust you with my life I
think that's a very short list for most
people but you say trust is easily
broken but it can be
rebuilt seems like that's needed now
that's right look uh uh if all of us if
all of us were perfectly reliable trust
wouldn't even matter right trust is what
you do when you can't be completely sure
of what somebody else will do but you
place some level of Faith you make
yourself a little bit vulnerable to them
and there are a lot of ways that as
human beings we uh restore trust when
it's been broken we rebuild trust when
it's been damaged that's something
America's got to think about a lot now
not just here at home where we've got to
find ways to reform our institutions but
around the world because we need uh
countries around the world to trust the
us more yeah Mr Mayor you know trust has
many enemies one of them is lies uh
secrets don't help either and and
particularly when they don't seem to be
that uh consequential so I am curious
why not just say whether or not you're
playing the Vice President in these mock
debates to prepare Senator Harris yeah
good question Tony deel what do you say
p
[Laughter]
bu look I'm not going to talk out of
school but uh I am very excited for
tomorrow night okay we're going to take
that as a yes yeah we'll take that as a
as a non- denial confirmation a lot of
people will be watching many people
thought VP can VP debate who's going to
be watching this one seems to have been
taking taking on a different tone would
you
agree absolutely it's uh it's so
important and uh I think a lot of
Americans are going to be tuning in to
see just a dramatic contrast between a
vice president defending the
indefensible and Senator Harris who uh
uh who has the the right message for the
right ticket for the right direction for
this country he Buddha jedge thank you
very much the book again is called trust
and it goes on sale today we'll be right
back